Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Connaissez-vous Sailly-Laurette ?
C’est un petit village au bord
de la Somme, de 340 habitants,
à 25 kilomètres d’Amiens.
Il y a une jolie église,
pas de commerces -
si, un café -
le silence, le chant des oiseaux.
Il est entouré de terres fertiles
agricoles sur des dizaines de kilomètres.
Bref, des champs.
J’ai découvert ce petit village -
j’avais treize ans -
Lorsque ma mère décide de s’y installer
et d’y ouvrir un restaurant.
Elle quitte tout, son travail,
vend la maison amiénoise
pour se lancer dans la restauration
alors que ce n’était pas son métier.
Imaginez-vous pour moi,
en pleine adolescence,
venir vivre à Sailly-Laurette,
à treize ans, ce n’est pas le paradis.
Je quitte Amiens, la ville,
la vie, pour la campagne.
À quinze ans,
après avoir longuement insisté,
j’arrive à convaincre ma mère de
me laisser retourner vivre seule à Amiens
pour être plus près de mon lycée.
Vous l'avez compris, c'était mon excuse.
Étudiante, je pars à Paris.
Après des études de droit,
j’opte pour une première expérience
professionnelle d’attachée de presse.
Je rencontre alors une journaliste.
Elle porte sur le corps des petits
cristaux façon tatouage éphémère.
C'est le coup de foudre, le déclic.
Mais oui, créer de véritables bijoux
qui se poseraient à même la peau,
sans attache et repositionnables,
créer une marque qui serait connue.
Je commence à avoir
des rêves plein la tête.
Mais je n'ai pas le capital de départ
pour ouvrir mon entreprise.
Telle la résultante d’un coup de foudre,
la passion l’emporte
et j’ose, je fonce, je risque.
Je quitte Paris, et à 25 ans,
je décide de revenir où ?
À Sailly-Laurette.
À Sailly-Laurette,
dans ce village que j’ai fui,
dans l’ancien restaurant de Maman,
pour m’y sentir rassurée,
bénéficier de l’espace,
ne pas payer de loyer
et y démarrer mon activité.
Je pense n’y rester que quelques mois,
vous l’avez compris.
Comment créer une marque
de luxe à Sailly-Laurette ?
Impossible pour moi à l'époque.
Je décide de prendre une adresse
de domiciliation à Paris,
rue de la Boétie,
dans le huitième arrondissement.
Plus chic.
La mode, c'est Paris, New York, Tokyo.
Pas Sailly-Laurette -
en tout cas, pas dans ma tête.
Je n’étais pas prête à affirmer
la ruralité de mon entreprise.
Les portes du monde de la mode
et du luxe sont difficiles à ouvrir
et le choix de l’implantation du lieu me
semblait être stratégiquement important.
Mais c’est difficile
et j’y reste longtemps.
Les mois passent et deviennent une année.
Tout l’argent est réinvesti
dans le développement
pour financer les matières premières.
Et je vis toujours à Sailly-Laurette.
Je commence à perdre espoir,
mais je me convaincs de persévérer.
Il y a des phrases simples
que l’on peut se répéter en soi.
La mienne était :
« N’abandonne pas.
Continue de croire en tes rêves. »
En 2005, je travaille sans relâche.
Mais les portes ne s'ouvrent toujours pas.
En décembre, une amie m’invite
à venir fêter le Nouvel an à Lisieux.
J’étais un peu désespérée :
j’allais devoir tout arrêter.
Le 1er janvier 2006, 10 h, je me rends à
la basilique de Sainte-Thérèse de Lisieux
pour y brûler un cierge
et demander de l'aide.
Trois jours plus tard,
je vivais ce que j’ai l’impression
d’être mes premiers miracles.
C’était peut-être le résultat
d’un travail acharné.
Je laisse à chacun
l’interprétation qu’il préfère.
Le 3 janvier, on m'annonce que Renaud
Dutreil, ministre des PME à l'époque,
allait me remettre le prix
de la diversité entrepreneuriale.
Le 25 janvier, le plus sélect salon
de la mode à Paris, Première Classe,
m’annonce que ma marque a été sélectionnée
comme la marque Coup de cœur du salon.
Et enfin, en février, le grand magasin
parisien Le Printemps Haussmann
m'invite à y exposer quinze jours.
Ça y est, (Souffle) c’est enfin parti.
J'ai bien fait de continuer
de croire en mes rêves.
Mais un rêve, ça se partage.
Je me souviens de tellement de rencontres.
Un jour, le make up artist d’une des plus
prestigieuses marques françaises -
vous savez, c’est celui qui crée
les maquillages sur les défilés -
m’appelle et me lance un défi.
Il avait découvert les bijoux
sur les réseaux sociaux.
Pourrions-nous leur créer
des bijoux pour les yeux
pour leur défilé du surlendemain ?
Des bijoux de peau,
c’est notre spécialité.
Des bijoux pour les yeux,
cela n'existait pas.
Ce serait une première mondiale.
J’en parle à mon équipe :
Odile, Nadège, Christine, Christelle.
A Sailly-Laurette, ce sont essentiellement
des femmes qui travaillent à l’atelier.
Elles vivent toutes dans le village
ou aux alentours.
Tout le monde se connaît.
D’ailleurs, à mes débuts, le mari
de Nadège, une de mes coéquipières,
était même venu en renfort
et avait proposé de repeindre l’atelier.
Les bijoux aujourd’hui,
c’est leur savoir-faire.
Nous les appelons les « Précieuses ».
Nous n’avons pas de machines, juste
nos mains, nos yeux, notre expertise.
La veille du défilé de la Fashion Week,
nous sommes à Sailly-Laurette.
Nos petites mains
sont attelées à la finition
de cette commande
si exclusive et innovante.
Que fait-on à Sailly-Laurette
lorsque l’on attend quelqu’un ?
On guette à la fenêtre.
Eh oui ! Moi aussi, je guettais.
Nous devions remettre les créations
à un chauffeur envoyé par la marque.
Une grosse berline arrive
et se gare sur le parking.
Nous n'avions pas du tout
fini la production.
Un homme d’âge mûr,
d’une grande élégance, descend.
Je m'en souviens comme si c'était hier.
On aurait dit qu'il était sorti
d'un magazine de mode.
Il portait un costume trois pièces
et une belle cravate rose.
Je lui ouvre et je me demande
ce qu’il va penser de l’atelier.
Le faire attendre 30 minutes
et devoir lui parler
m’avait un petit peu impressionnée.
Mais finalement, je suis stupéfaite.
Il me dit : « C’est ici que vous créez ?
Ça me rappelle mon village en Italie.
Cela fait 30 ans
que je n’y suis pas retourné.
C'est pourtant un endroit cher à mon cœur,
en pleine campagne comme ici.
Je me souviens, les gens s’aidaient.
Les gens disaient peu
mais faisaient beaucoup. »
Ça m'a fait réfléchir.
C’est vrai, la solidarité,
c’est Sailly-Laurette.
Mais un rêve, ça se partage
et ça se propage.
Je me souviens de tellement de rencontres
et chaque rencontre est importante.
En 2010, une dame de Dubaï,
habituée aux grandes villes,
a fait spécialement l’aller-retour
pour venir à l’atelier.
Elle venait valider nos collections
de bijoux de peau pour le Moyen-Orient.
Là aussi, j’ai eu peur.
Dubaï - Sailly-Laurette,
c’est le choc des cultures.
Elle était émerveillée
de découvrir la campagne française
et sûrement pour la première fois
de sa vie, un village.
Elle a adoré le chant des oiseaux,
le calme, la verdure
et voir les vaches dans les pâtures.
J’ai oublié de vous dire tout à l’heure,
je vais le mettre ici,
que lorsque j’étais désespérée
et que j’essayais de me remonter le moral,
un de mes voisins agriculteurs était venu
frapper énergiquement à la porte
pour m’annoncer une bonne nouvelle :
« Adeline, un veau est né cette nuit
et je l’ai appelé Adeline. »
(Rires)
Donc elle a sûrement vu ma vache.
Un rêve, ça se partage,
ça se propage encore et encore.
En 2018, nous avons créé
une marque, M Paris,
pour vendre nos bijoux et les faire
connaître en vente en réunion.
Des femmes entrepreneures,
ou qui ont envie d’oser,
nous rejoignent en tant qu’ambassadrices.
Nous les appelons les « M Girls »,
inspirées de 007.
Elles sont 150 et elles font la promotion
des bijoux dans les capitales,
mais aussi dans les campagnes.
En plus de l’équipe qui oscille
entre dix et 30 personnes à l’atelier,
aujourd'hui, je ne suis plus seule.
Mon énergie aujourd’hui, c’est pour elles,
pour toutes ces personnes
qui m’accompagnent,
qui considèrent l’entreprise
comme la leur,
pour celles qui portent nos bijoux parce
que nous partageons les mêmes valeurs,
ainsi qu’avec les associés
et les actionnaires, maintenant.
Nos valeurs, c’est la liberté,
l’audace et la solidarité.
Et grâce à elles, nous pouvons aider
d’autres femmes grâce à des associations,
en les soutenant pour qu'elles continuent
de croire en leurs rêves.
Ce que je pensais être un frein au départ,
démarrer mon activité à Sailly-Laurette,
était en réalité une véritable force.
Je ne sais pas ce qui vient,
mais je sais tous les cadeaux
que j’ai reçus de cette terre picarde.
Je sais que je suis fière
de dire aujourd’hui :
Sailly-Laurette, New York, Tokyo, Paris.
Mon message ce soir, c’est de vous
dire de ne jamais abandonner.
Croyez toujours en vos rêves.
(Applaudissements)